donald trump's first speech as our
former president included some of the
same
false claims that inspired the deadly
assault on the capitol
and he expressed no remorse instead he
used yesterday's 90-minute address at
the conservative political action
conference to attack his political
enemies including
fellow republicans as ed o'keefe reports
mr trump also laid out his plans
to continue leading the party
do you miss me yet do you miss me
even out of the white house former
president trump is shaking up politics
we all knew that the biden
administration was going to be bad
but none of us even imagined just how
bad
they would be and how far left they
would go while former president obama
often spoke out about trump after
leaving office
trump's desire to stay engaged in the
political spotlight is unprecedented
after all we've never had a one-term
twice impeached former president
leave office with an unusually large
political follower
and while he said he has no intention of
officially splitting up the gop
we have the republican party it's going
to unite and be stronger than ever
before
trump highlighted the rift in the party
by taking time to call out by name
more than a dozen republican lawmakers
who either voted to impeach or convict
him last month
for inciting the riot at the capitol
of course the warmonger a person that
loves
seeing our troops fighting liz cheney
polls show a majority of republicans
would support a trump 2024 campaign
even as he remains the subject of
multiple criminal investigations
so if he doesn't run in 2024 more than a
dozen
other republicans are making
preparations and several
spoke at cpac kovid didn't crush the
economy
government crushed the economy i hear
president biden saying
america's back
back to what but speakers mostly embrace
the trump legacy
i hope on january 20th 2025 he is once
again the leader of
our great country the conference also
included the former president and many
other activists
discussing unsubstantiated claims of
election interference
those conversations came as more than 40
states are now considering
republican proposals to change election
laws most would limit the number of
early voting days and hours or put in
place
stricter voter id rules for absentee
ballot scale
and i hadn't thought about it the way
you phrased it a one-term twice
impeached president well
he's certainly that and the former
president flirted with the idea of a
2024 white house run many times in his
speech but he didn't just come out and
say he was going to run why do you think
he didn't do that
well aids tell me that legally and from
a fundraising standpoint he can't do all
this other work he wants to do for
republicans if he's an officially
declared candidate himself so
he may want to run again we'll see but
first he wants to continue being a king
maker
besides gail we know he enjoys keeping
everyone on his toes yes
or on our toes yeah so for now he's
going to keep us in suspense
all of the above the crowd was certainly
glad to see him yesterday thank you very
much ed the crowd in the room